hey 42 here the oldest person to have
ever lived was a French woman Jeanne
Calment
who lived to the age of 122 years and
164 days as modern medicine and living
standards improve so does our life
expectancy but will the day soon come
when life has no cup some scientists
believe it to be much more than just
science fiction to understand how humans
can live forever we first need to
understand what aging actually is a lot
of people think aging is a very complex
process but it's really quite simple
aging is basically a side effect of
being alive all our body's normal
day-to-day processes such as breathing
moving and digesting food gradually
cause wear and tear on ourselves and
after a certain amount of wear and tear
our cells die causing permanent damage
to our bodies our bodies can only take
so much of this cell damage so
eventually we die think of your body
like a car driving it around causes
unavoidable wear and tear to all of its
components until one day it gives up and
refuses to start unless you perform
regular maintenance on it such as
changing the oil or even replacing
entire parts some revolutionary
scientists have taken this same
mechanical view on the human body and
believed that with regular maintenance
and even replacing damaged organs we can
keep our bodies running smoothly
indefinitely in 2011 surgeons in Sweden
perform the world's first organ
transplant using a synthetic organ that
was grown in a lab the organ was grown
by London scientists in just a few days
but most importantly the synthetic
windpipe was grown using the patient's
own DNA meaning there was no chance of
the body rejecting the new organ the 36
year-old cancer patient is now doing
fine after the transplant scientists are
now working on doing the same thing with
flex organs such as hearts and lungs and
they predict that in less than 10 years
any organ will be able to be grown in a
lab on demand in unlimited quantities
without the need for donors but
immortality could potentially manifest
itself in many ways Biogen want ologist
marius carry aziz believes that
immortality is not an if but a when he
theorizes that immortality is an
inevitable consequence of evolution his
theory states that through evolution the
human brain will one day become so
complex it will be capable of sustaining
our bodies for an indefinite amount of
time by slowing down the aging process
and stopping it completely when the body
is fully grown but evolution is an
awfully slow process if you're looking
for a more immediate solution to eternal
youth you may be surprised to hear
there's a lot more research going on in
this field than you might imagine in
2005 a british scientist named or Britta
gray set up a research foundation called
Sens which stands for strategies for
engineered negligible senescence the aim
of Sens is to research and develop a
diverse range of regenerative medical
therapies to not only stop the aging
process in humans but also reversing
Aubry believes that death is not an
inevitability but merely a disease which
can be cured with the correct medical
treatment in order to lengthen our lives
we simply have to extend the length of
our telomeres which are capped at the
end of our DNA that shorten as we age
leading to the breakdown of cells the
answer is simple if we can develop a
pill to lengthen our telomeres we can
stop and even reverse the aging process
audrey believes that we will have
realistic aid preventive medicine
available to us in as little as 25 years
and that the first person who will live
to be a thousand years old has already
been born but or Breda grey isn't the
own
scientists interested in living forever
scientist and director of engineering at
Google Ray Kurzweil is a prominent
futurist and has accurately predicted
many of today's advanced technologies
years in advance because our
understanding of genes and computer
technology is accelerating at an
incredible rate ray made a bold
prediction that in just 20 years time
humans will have developed super
advanced microscopic nanobots that will
be able to enter our bodies in their
millions and perform the same jobs as
our board cells but a thousand times
more effectively keeping our bodies a
hundred percent infection free and
instantly repairing any damaged cells
enabling us to live indefinitely and
even reverse aging what ray predicts
that this is not all that nanotechnology
will be able to achieve in the very near
future
he predicts that within 25 years we will
be able to use nanotechnology to modify
our bodies and obtain superhuman powers
for example we will be able to go scuba
diving for hours without oxygen we will
be able to extend our mental capacities
to such an extent that we will be able
to write books within minutes and in our
daily lives hologram like figures will
pop into our brain and explain to us
what's happening the potentials for
nanotechnology are limitless and many
scientists agree that at our current
rate of technological advancements it
won't be long before nanotechnology and
nano bots are part of our everyday lives
changing the way and for how long we
live our lives but if all else fails you
can always freeze your body after you
die and hope that sometime in the future
scientists will be able to revive your
frozen cadaver and bring you back to
life this is called cryonics and you may
have only seen it in films but it's
actually a real science the process
involves refrigerating the body in
liquid nitrogen and replacing the blood
with
Oh protectant fluid to prevent ice
crystals forming inside the body and
damaging the cells the body is then
suspended upside down in giant steel
containers so the head always stays the
coldest and the temperature is then
lowered to minus 196 degrees centigrade
there are currently over 250 bodies
preserved in this way waiting for
science to revive that and more than a
thousand living people have signed up
for the procedure but it doesn't come
cheap it cost around two hundred
thousand dollars for a full-body
preservation although you can just get
your head preserved for slightly cheaper
and hope that one day science will be
advanced enough to connect your head to
another body and bring it back to life
with all your memories preserve all this
talk of immortality is very exciting and
maybe a lot closer than you may think
but what will happen when a certain
portion of humanity refuses to die it's
commonly a topic of heated debate
overpopulation is already a global issue
until we are able to find of a planet to
inhabit the unfortunate truth remains
that we need people to die earth can
only support so many people well that's
not the only problem
1% of the world's population own 50% of
the world's wealth and if those few
people refused to die there won't be any
more wealth distribution they will only
continue to further monopolize two
global markets and the rich will become
richer whilst the poor grow poorer
another caveat is that the retirement
age would shoot up to hundreds of years
this is fine for the ambitious few who
seek premium jobs and luxurious
lifestyles but imagine being forced to
work over a thousand years flipping
burgers at McDonald's in an immortal
Society criminal punishment will become
greatly devalued 30 years behind bars is
nothing for someone with a lifespan of
thousands of years and with such a lousy
deterrent crime could increase
dramatically also with the value of
one's life being so much higher
death sentences wouldn't be given out so
frequently and we may have to invest
heavily in rehabilitation techniques or
even brainwashing techniques to keep
your moody side of society under control
but there are benefits to an immortal
population we will finally be able to
send people to explore other planets
that would otherwise take more than a
lifetime to reach also those few
Einstein like people and Mongols who
have brilliant minds will live forever
and so their knowledge will continue to
grow and contribute to the global
knowledge bank as a result human
knowledge will grow as an unprecedented
rate society will advance and develop
new technologies at an astonishing
ever-increasing rate thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2